CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was homeland
security and counterterrorism advisor
for president george w bush and she is
joining us live Fran good to see you
plausible is this interrogation gone
wrong narrative from the Saudis well
there's a couple of problems with this
right of course that one they've been
saying that he left the consulate that
the 15n team was were tourists and just
this weekend that they said these
allegations that he was killed inside
the consulate were baseless now they're
gonna do a complete 180 now you know
even we understand first reports are
always wrong and it takes a while for
leadership to get the true facts but
even with that right if you're gonna say
that you authorized the interrogation
and potential snatch once you once
you've authorized that you're
responsible you have responsibility if
anything goes wrong and so there I think
all of this belies the credibility of
the Saudis and and it underscores look I
think the Americans and the Saudis are
looking for a way to get past this what
does it mean Fran to have the President
of the United States come forward and
say that he spoke with the king of Saudi
Arabia who denied involvement and then
float this theory of rogue killers even
before we heard of these leaks well you
know nor I I you say to yourself how
rogue are these people right because if
the if you say you authorised even if
it's not the king right and the king was
not part of this if the crown prince
authorized the interrogation and
potential snatch you then look at who
are these people who are on this 15 man
team one of whom are alleged to have
been a forensics autopsy expert and
that's a problem what was he doing there
if all you had to authorized was an
interrogation and a snatch now I think
we ought to be to be fair here the Turks
have made outrageous allegations about
having audios and videos we've seen no
evidence we've only seen anonymous leaks
out of Turkey and Turkey itself does not
have a great human rights record or
frankly remember that they were the
beatings of protesters here in the
United States a year ago so the Turks
have not exactly been playing this
straight either Fran pardon me tell me
your sense of the
oral calculus here obviously there's the
moral question of the death of a human
being but there's the United States
position with Saudi Arabia and the
message it sends about human rights to
Saudi Arabia but then as Senator Rubio's
said there's a message this sends to
Vladimir Putin to other people across
all the other authoritarian regimes
across the globe how do you where do you
think that message gets sent John look
we ought to recognize that this these
sort of horrible incidents are on the
rise whether it's the Iranians trying to
kill the Saudi ambassador here in the
United States or dissidents and
Americans in Paris or it's Vladimir
Putin poisoning people in the UK and now
this right we we we have to take a stand
and we have to be clear or else absent
some reaction from the United States and
others frankly it becomes open season on
dissidents and journalists around the
world and that's what we're seeing right
we're seeing increasing incidents like
this because we and others have not
taken a strong stand yes and if it was
an interrogation gone wrong why don't
not admit that where is the body where
is was where are the remains of mr.
khashoggi today that's still a question
nobody knows the answer to that's right
thank you very much Fran Townsend for
joining us this morning